so where we left off in the last video
we have the neo-babylonians the chaldean
empire being conquered by the persians
led by cyrus the great that's in 539
that cyrus the great conquers
babylon
and they're able to establish a
significant empire
and his successor campuses ii in
525 bce is able to do something that
many of the conquerors that we've talked
about in the last few videos were not
able to do and conquers egypt and makes
that part of the persian empire and so
the persian empire is this vast and
significant empire that gets created in
this time period but they soon run up to
a i guess you could say a group of
city-states a civilization that is able
to fend off the persians and so just to
be clear what we're talking about or
what i just talked about
here we are in five in roughly
539 bce
where you have
where you have cyrus the great is able
to take over the neo-babylonian empire
and in doing so going back to references
from the old testament ends the
babylonian captivity of the jewish
people is able to free the jewish people
and then his successor kanbacees in 5
and
525 bce is able to take over egypt and
so you see this expansion of the persian
empire on this timeline as well but then
they run up against the ancient greeks
and the ancient greeks were not a
unified nation they were a group of
city-states when people talk about
city-states it's cities like athens that
are associated with the ionians that
settled several hundred years ago in
that region the spartans associated with
the dorians who also
moved down several hundred years before
the time period we're talking about they
each had each city was its own state it
had its own military it had its own laws
and traditions but they also had things
in common they shared a they shared
language they shared traditions they
shared they shared religion
and the persians and i'll do many videos
on this because it is fascinating were
not able to conquer and now this is
under the successors of cyrus the great
or the successor of cyrus the great and
kanbaceys
we have darius the great is not able in
multiple attempts to take over the
greeks and these are the famous
greco-persian wars which occur from 499
bce
to 450
b
c e
greco
greco persian
persian
wars and our map we see it right over
here the greco-persian wars and there
are some famous instances famous events
from uh why we now run a marathon to the
movie 300 where you have the stand that
the spartans attempted to take at
thermopylae uh
where the the persian army with
thousands and thousands of soldiers
facing 300 spartans and several hundred
other soldiers say give us your arms and
once again we don't know how much of
this is legend and how much is true but
it's a good story and the spartans say
come and take them and then the persians
say we have enough arrows to blot out
the sun and the spartans say good then
we will fight in the shade so the the
greco-persian wars
they happened and they're also the stuff
of legend and some great stories and
great movies even have come out of the
out of those wars
now even though
the city-states of greece were able to
fend off the persians in this time
period they're not able to unify in fact
they start fighting each other and
that's when you start having the
peloponnesian wars so 431
from
b
c e to 404
b c e
you have
you have the pelo
peloponnesian
peloponnesian i should say the
peloponnesian war
and that is between sparta and its
allies and athens and its allies and
we'll once again do more videos on this
but sparta is this militaristic society
athens famous for its culture it's
learning
but they're able to give each other a
good fight now can you imagine while
they are fighting each other it leaves
them open to be conquered by someone
else and that someone else ends up being
philip of macedon
and the macedonians are a related people
they share a similar language they have
similar traditions and philip of macedon
is able to take over most of what we now
consider to be greece
and as famous as phil as famous as
philip of macedon is his son is perhaps
one of the top five most famous people
in history because in 336
philip of macedon dies
he's actually assassinated
and his son alexander the great takes
over and his son is only 20 years old
and he wasn't called alexander the great
when it started but when he was done
they called him alexander alexander the
great so alexander takes over i'll write
this down he's 20 20 years old and he
quickly consolidates power
not over not only over greece but he
starts establishing a an empire where
he's able to take over not now the shoes
on the other foot he's able to take over
much of what was
the persian empire
he actually is able to take his armies
all the way to the borders of india he's
taking over egypt much of the middle
east
and so this is often referred to as the
world's greatest adventure and it's
fascinating because he does this over a
little bit more than a decade he dies in
323.
so 323
bce
alexander dies so he's in his early 30s
and he managed to do this unfort well
whether you depending on what side of
history you're on fortunately or
unfortunately his empire isn't able to
last so you could see this on our
timeline alexander in that brief you
know a little bit more than a decade
he's able to take over all of this all
of this territory he's able to get his
armies to the borders of
of india
and and but then because he dies
short-lived the empire does not last it
actually gets split into multiple
empires people who are related or the
generals of alexander we'll do many
videos about that split but maybe more
interestingly while that is happening at
the time of alexander another
another group is emerging that will
eventually turn into one of the greatest
empires that the world has ever seen and
that is the romans that we see or they
are the romans that we will see in the
next video you can see it on this
timeline
right over here